What's up guys, my name is Colin McNeil for
theScore esports.
A great man once posed the question, what's
beef?
Well to answer it, beef is when two people
or organizations have an on-going, mutually
disrespectful relationship.
So for this Top 10, we scoured the esports
landscape.
From Halo to League of Legends to find you
the spiciest rivalries we could.
So without further ado let's get on with
it.
Here are the Top 10 esports beefs.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is TSM Reginald
versus CLG’s Hotshot GG
The TSM and CLG owners have fostered one of
esports' premiere rivalries since 2010, when
Reginald played
for CLG.
"I used to play with Regi, I used to be on a team with him.
And,  it was for a short time, a very very short time."
Their individual rivalry quickly moved on to
the rift.
(Casting)
After they became full time owners, the beef
went public.
The rivalry would often include humiliating
bets.
The beef evolved to the point where playing
for either team meant beefing with the other.
"Against CLG my sodium levels kinda go out of control."
"They just have TSM's number."
"They're just FreeSM, you know?"
"As far as I know, the only NA team I'm worried about is Cloud 9. The rest are non-existent. Especially CLG."
To date TSM has won four more NA LCS Splits,
but CLG routinely posts strong results.
CLG even beat TSM at Madison Square Gardens
in 2015 to claim an NA LCS Championship of
their own.
A beef that started between two former players
has had a rippling effect on the two teams,
a rivalry that is still felt today.
"Hello and welcome to the Shanghai Major, presented by Perfect World. "
Dota 2’s Shanghai Major was problematic
for many reasons, but one controversy stands
above the rest: the firing of James “2GD”
Harding, which comes it at number nine on
our list.
"So last night, I was perusing the hotel entertainment.
It turned out, censorship, the Chinese hotel had disabled pornography.
Don't get me wrong I watched it.
Mr. Wang's amazing wheelchaired antics were pretty amazing."
"You can f--k off, Winter."
For his controversial commentary, Valve CEO
Gabe Newell made headlines by publicly denouncing
and firing Harding, calling him an ass in
a Reddit post.
"Two things. James. We've had issues with James at previous events.
Some Valve people lobbied to bring him back for Shanghai, feeling that he deserved another chance.
That was a mistake. James is an ass, and we won't be working with him again."
Harding tried to clear his name and posted
screenshots of a conversation with Dota 2
developer IceFrog telling him to be himself.
These days the infamous caster has retired
from the game, and is playing professional
Quake Champions.
Coming in at number eight is Snip3down versus
Lethul.
Yes, we are talking about a Halo beef.
One week before the 2016 X-Games in Aspen,
Lethul left Evil Geniuses and joined rival
team CLG.
"If there is one player on EG that you feel like you need to shut down
who is that player?"
"Probably Snip3down, he's like the best player, he's just so sick.
You know, I get really worried when I see him and it's just the stuff he does is insane."
"Alright well any words here Snip3down?"
"I remember what happened the last time that exact quote was said to me
so watch your face."
That led EG team captain Snip3down to post
a tell-all YouTube video that explained the
situation.
"I thought T.J. and I were friends.
I feel like it was pretty out of the blue move.
He didn't really communicate well with us at all with this.
Best of luck to him in whatever he decides to choose
I really hope that it comes to bite him in the ass."
The antics continued when the X-Games rolled
around.
EG would go on to win gold after a tight seven-game
series, and Snip3down did not let Lethul forget
it.
"I told him before it started the last person that said that to me lost the series
and they lost the series too.
So if you're going to talk trash you better back it up and we took that series home."
After the X-Games, CLG would win the HCS World
Championship.
A roster shake-up would follow for the rest
of the league, and Snip3down left EG.
Snip3down went on to join a dream team with
Envyus and the rivalry continued.
Number seven goes to Doublelift and Aphromoo.
The relationship between teammates is crucial
to craft a successful team.
In late-2015, CLG’s League of Legends squad
underwent some massive changes as star AD
carry Doublelift left the team to join TSM,
leaving his long-time support Aphromoo.
Doublelift and Aphromoo were friends, holding
down CLG’s bot lane for three years together.
The duo tag-teamed many interviews together,
and were widely considered one of the best
bot lanes in LCS history, calling themselves
Rush Hour.
Doublelift accused Aphromoo of forcing an
ultimatum on CLG.
"The truth is Aphro went to the org and he said
it's either me or him referring to me, and I'm not playing with Peter next year."
The two players continued to make comments
back-and-forth on stream and in post game interviews.
"The best decision moving forward, only because Peter
brings people down more often than not."
"Me and CLG had a falling out are you and Aphro still buddies?
No. Not really.
But a falling out is one way to put it for sure."
Now, two have since made up, even bot laning
again together at the League of Legends All-Star
event in 2016.
Reginald and Tryndamere didn't have the most
dramatic beef, but certainly one of the
most impactful, which is why it comes in at
number six on our list.
During the 2016 NA LCS Summer Split, TSM owner
Reginald spoke out on how Riot’s major patches
affected the League of Legends competitive
scene.
"It's really scary to own an esports team.
Because the patches change a lot.
And so when you own a team and the patches change in a really unfavorable way
for your players, then there is a higher chance that you'll do bad and you can get relegated.
How the system works if you get relegated you're done. And because the Challenger
is so weak if you get relegated you pretty much lose everything."
How did Riot respond?
Well, Riot co-founder Marc ‘Tryndamere’
Merrill took to Reddit to explain, coining
the very meme-worthy phrase, “Love me some Regi."
"Love me some Regi, but if he’s so concerned about the financial health of his players
maybe he should spend some more of the millions he has made / makes
from League of Legends on paying them instead of investing in other eSports where he is losing money?
Regi is one of the generally “good guy” team owners
But when owners don’t want to shell out for top talent, that’s a tricky problem.
We intentionally prioritized game health and viewer experience
Over the ability for teams / coaches to field 'safer' comps by lane swapping."
The back-and-forth sparked a bigger conversation
within the league, arguably paving the way
for NA LCS franchising.
Coming in at number five, Sonic Fox vs Perfect Legend.
Summer Jam 9 featured a Mortal Kombat X grudge
match between Sonic Fox and Perfect Legend.
It started over a Twitter beef, and ended
with Sonic Fox mopping the floor with Perfect
Legend, beating him 10-0.
Perfect Legend followed up his 10-0 loss by
downplaying Sonic Fox’s win, claiming the
original Twitter beef centred around
Fox’s Erron Black versus his Kung Lao.
"What I did say, I would destroy his Erron Black, as you saw, that character was not on screen."
Tournament organizer Eric ‘Big E’ Small
quickly grabbed the mic from PL, and well,
you can see what happened next.
"So do we have a three-to-five with the Erron Black?
three-out-of-five with the Erron Black? Three-out-of-five with the Erron Black?"
That’s right.
Immediately after the loss Big E made them
play again.
Sonic Fox’s Erron Black versus Perfect Legend’s
Kung Lao.
And well, this one ended in similar fashion
to the games before it, a three round sweep,
and a 13-0 final score.
Coming in at number four, StarCraft 2 pros
HuK and IdrA.
The two players had a history.
HuK was an up-and-comer at the time, just
beginning his career in StarCraft 2.
While IdrA was a veteran in the scene, starting
his career early in StarCraft: Brood War.
There developed a hatred between the two.
"He's a piece of trash who wouldn't win any games if he didn't play Protoss."
The beef peaked at MLG Dallas 2011, where
their rivalry was perfectly summarized by
one play.
"IdrA....left the game?"
HuK used hallucinated void rays to overwhelm
IdrA, who left the game thinking he'd lost.
Of course, the hallucinations never dealt
any actual damage to IdrA.
HuK was sure to bring it up in the next game.
The two would continue to battle until August
of 2011, when Evil Geniuses announced HuK
was joining their team, finally putting the rest this esports beef.
Leffen and Hungrybox’s relentless hate for
each other comes in at number three on this
list.
Leffen and Hungrybox are both Super Smash
Bros. Melee players at the top of their esport.
They also really hate each other.
Hungrybox famously claims he only attended
Genesis 5 to kick Leffen’s ass.
"It was the only reason I came to this tournament. I want to kick that guy's ass."
The two have beefed in-game and of course over Twitter
HBox also went on stream to gloat about beating
Leffen at Smash Summit 5.
"I three-oned his ass, three-oned him. Get f--ked. All your sh-t talk, get f--ked Leffen."
Leffen published a video to his YouTube, from
his stream, called “One of the Many Reasons
to Dislike Hbox”.
"The saying, there are two kind's of people in this world. HBox fans, and people who've met him."
One of the most infamous rivalries in the
FGC, KBrad and Wolfkrone do not hold back,
and that's why they are second on this list
of esports beefs.
Their particular beef began in 2016, when
Wolfkrone wiped his hands of KBrad after beating
him in Street Fighter V at Frosty Faustings
9.
The beef escalated online, with tweets and
Facebook posts running rampant.
KBrad got his revenge, and at the Capcom Pro
Tour, he slammed Wolfkrone in a 2-0 series.
No respect has been shown in this beef and
the hatred between the two is high.
"Will this beef ever end or is this everlasting now?"
"I think there's something wrong with him. I legit think there's something wrong with his head."
The culmination of their beef thus far is
undoubtedly their run-in at
ELEAGUE’s Street Fighter V Invitational.
"He's telling every excuse, 'I just can't deal with it, I just don't know how.' Every excuse is coming out the book now."
"As a player, I used to always fist-bump him I used to always shake his hand
until he started talking trash.
But as a person, I just don't like him."
"Straight up, what are your thoughts on that man?"
"Who gives a f-ck."
"What did you do to change things here this tournament?"
"I mean I really didn't do anything, it's kinda felt a point for me
after we beat OpTic at Columbus. I don't want to say anything got boring but I was just kinda focusing on
other things."
OpTic gaming versus FaZe, a tale of two Call of Duty
giants, tops our list of esports beefs.
The two teams would battle for online turf,
both producing similar YouTube content in
the early days of their respective orgs.
OpTic would be the first to take on esports,
braving the rocky shores of the early scene.
FaZe would eventually make their debut in
esports, bringing their large fanbase with
them.
Two giants, coming from the same place, now
had an arena to duke it out in.
While OpTic had a huge head start, FaZe was
hot on their tail.
"FaZe takes UMG."
In the early days, OpTic and FaZe ran the
YouTube community online, and you either liked
OpTic or FaZe.
Never both.
While the Faze and Optic rivalry has calmed
down since, the impact of this esports beef
can still be felt today.
Well guys if that wasn't some USDA Approved
Choice cut Prime beef, I don't know what is.
But if you think there is an esports beef
that should have been in our top ten list
and wasn't.
Well I got some bad news for you, you're just
wrong.